what like brings emotions to you the
story and the characters
and the performances okay but does not
buzz but does voice acting not
give you emotion yeah the voice acting
does okay so how come music can't do
that
dude i don't know i guess i can't like i
don't know it doesn't connect with me i
don't know
do you know a medium where you can feel
emotion just by story
and characters books books
you don't read books i don't want to
read the book i want someone to read it
for me
the music for me is something that like
ties it together and it's something that
if it's done well i don't notice and if
it's done badly i will notice
okay no i agree with that which is the
way i think that most people view
like voice acting no no i agree with how
if music is done well
i don't if it's done so well then
sometimes you can't notice it but
but then there's a level no because i
don't i don't look out for it like i i
don't see
no when i say when i say good i mean
like just it blends in
perfectly yeah satisfactory music you
don't notice it yeah but you will
definitely hear
when a soundtrack is really well there's
a track that they use in amazing ways
i'll notice that track and i'll like
have like a little
longer right but does that not give you
your emotions you've definitely heard
the sarino drop yeah yeah and i'm like
oh yeah i get a little hype about it
[Laughter]
oh my god have you ever watched like
okay
my my favorite soundtrack of whatsapp is
probably zankyuu no teda or
terian resonance i remember enjoying
that show a lot okay so i remember the
music was sad
i don't know about you so
much the music was sad
yes the music was sad it's like saying
pepper's off
when you when you talk about music to me
you need to filter it through like
the youtube audio library tags like
genre
and mood that's the only thing i
understand about music
tell me the genre of music and the mood
it works okay you watch zonk
yeah i love those okay it it had the
whole icelandic
uh like kind of post rock drone right
the motorbike scene where they're on
like the motor and it's nothing
but just no doubt no dialogue just them
riding on a motorbike with
beautiful visuals and beautiful music do
you remember that scene no
[Music]
i remember them being terrorists this is
i'm feeling so
[ __ ] frustrated now oh my god
i just remember them being like
terrorists right and it was fun anime
you remember them
i remember them blowing up [ __ ] that's
like saying attack on titans i remember
the being titans yeah
there's titan dude i remember enjoying
that show but like
when i finished like it's gone okay okay
okay then
let's let's steer away let's go down
let's go down to the most like
rudimentary level here let's let's go to
okay okay what is your favorite anime
opening
oh that's good i really like the kogias
one okay why
type is fun okay but what makes it like
like what emotions do you feel
when listening to it is it excitement is
it yeah
okay so how come you can put emotion
into that song
but what what makes what makes that
memorable yeah what makes that
yeah the the the opening part is pretty
high you know the the jumbo
that's just the meme yeah i love it
though it's good what else do i love i
mean the jojo the jojo openings hype is
fun
okay okay oh no no johanna do you wanna
steamed okay
okay why does that work why do you like
john why did that stand out
as i said in i think i tweeted it i was
like it's the bohemian rhapsody
what does that mean what does that mean
what is that because there's so much
[ __ ] going on it's like a five-minute
song and there's just like so many
[ __ ] things happening
and i'm like wow this is amazing
i don't know if it's the coffee or this
conversation but i'm basically getting a
headache
i'm getting like a brain aneurysm right
now i imagine the viewers at home are
like what is wrong with this kid
what's wrong i'm like dying inside just
listening to this
ah how about never had this conversation
with you before i guess because every
time you bring up music i think i just
go like yeah okay
you if we went to school together you
would be that one kid who would wear a
coco bean t-shirt not knowing who
nirvana was
i mean like to be like yeah i like his
face yeah i look it's like
that teen spirit song spirit yeah what
is it
looks like teen spirit so
okay what else do you value anything
else in an anime
aside from like story and characters
then um i mean the visuals are really
important
right like i feel that it's like it's
it's not so much that i don't appreciate
music it's again like i said like if
it's done well
it blends in and i don't really pay much
attention to it okay but you remember
the cowboy beerbot soundtrack yeah
okay why do you remember that i remember
it it went like really well with all the
cardio
like the well all the movements in that
show like blended so well yeah music and
i remember
it like made them both stand out more
than anything at the time when i was
watching right
because the car so your argument is that
because this
the feeling of the soundtrack is not an
argument so completely
i'm just saying like i'm not trying to
argue or anything i'm just saying that's
what i remember is because no no because
because you kind of
because you're logic from what i'm
understanding your logic is
that again i don't think about this too
much yeah well your logic is that the
cowboy bebop soundtrack you remember
because the feeling and vibe you got
from the music was so different to the
visuals
right no no because i can't put the
visuals without the music there
okay so how come you don't remember
zankyon ortera then because it does the
exact same thing i remember like
maybe like two scenes from san quinotera
literally and did they involve any music
no
i remember seeing the building exploded
i remember someone getting sniped and i
remember being sad by the sniped
i i i was expecting to say that you were
very impressed with the nose
i was very impressed with this man's aim
in a helicopter
very impressed you know must have some
very